Folks, it's official, we are entering the
Age of Unlightenment.
My friend, a true feminist in the best sense
of the word and a fearless defender of free
speech, Christina Hoff Sommers, was invited
to speak at Lewis and Clark Law School this
week.
Here's what happened when she began her talk...
Putting aside the creepiness of the clone-like
repetitive chanting from the protestors, their
use of free speech actually isn't a use free
speech at all.
While of course they have a right to protest,
your right to exercise your free speech doesn't
come at the expense of someone else's right
to exercise theirs.
So what this means is, yes, you CAN peacefully
protest outside of an event, you CAN silently
protest inside of an event, you CAN hold all
the signs you want and you CAN encourage others
to join your cause.
You canNOT, however, use your freedoms to
trample on the freedoms of others.
This chanting, which again took place before
Christina had even begun to speak, reminded
me of when I was at UCLA with Milo two years
ago.
Protestors screamed, spit, threw garbage cans,
pulled fire alarms and even called in bomb
threats before we even took the stage.
Perhaps the most egregious, though, was the
group of students who linked arms to create
a human wall to stop us and other viewers
from even going inside the venue itself.
So apparently they aren't against walls, they
just don't like Trump's wall.
Christina's talk continued through the chanting,
and the protestors then broke out in song...
Quite a catchy tune wouldn't you say?
Of course, Christina Hoff Sommers isn't a
fascist at all, she's just an old school liberal
who dare challenge modern day Leftist.
Ironically these people so keen on fighting
fascism don't understand that they themselves
are the ones who are actually using fascist
tactics of silencing and drowning out their
opponents until there is no opposition remaining
at all.
But if you're still confused, here's a simple
definition of fascism:
Fascism is a form of radical authoritarian
nationalism, characterized by dictatorial
power, forcible suppression of opposition
and control of industry and commerce, which
came to prominence in early 20th-century Europe.
Do you think Christina is for dictatorial
power?
Is she for forcible suppression of opposition?
To top it off she even works for the American
Enterprise Institute, which is against control
of industry and commerce.
Now just think for a moment if the ideas that
these students are espousing were the set
of ideas in power?
They actually would be for dictatorial control,
as they believe their cause is the most just
and their opponents are simply evil.
How do you think it would be going for dissent
and opposition in their system?
Perhaps the most insidious piece of the cultural
marxism that we see spreading on college campuses
is that it is using the freedoms that our
democratic capitalist society against itself.
Of course it would never offer the same protection
to minority voices in the dystopian future
that it would bring.
While this event thankfully wasn't nearly
as violent as when Milo when to UC Berkely
and the school burned down, or when it took
600K in security to ensure that Ben Shapiro
could speak there without threat, this display
at Lewis and Clark is just another reminder
of how the backwards thinking of cultural
marxism is coming for all dissenters, cloaked
in the mask of tolerance and diversity.
These incidences are happening at colleges
all over the country and turning places of
higher learning into places where people are
just getting high...on intersectionality.
Sadly, this story really only broke on right
leaning blogs and was only shared by the usual
suspects who continually defend freedom of
expression.
As of recording this, I haven't see any Left
leaning websites that covered it.
The reason for this of course is two-fold,
on one hand when you can win arguments by
silencing your opponents, your job is pretty
easy, but also, and more importantly, the
good actors on the Left who want to call out
events like this rarely do because they know
that the same tactics of smearing and silencing
will be used against them as they are purged
from their former home.
Just ask former guests of mine like Bret Weinstein,
Laura Kipnis, Lindsay Shepherd and others,
who dare speak out against this tyrannical
faux diversity movement.
The silver lining though, of course, is that
the more that people like Bret, Laura and
Lindsay speak out, the more room they give
for people like you to do the same in your
life.
Speaking of Berkeley, I'll be there, tomorrow
Thursday night, hosted by the the Berkeley
College Republicans.
I'll be joined by Heather McDonald and Steve
Simpson.
We'll be live steaming the event right here
at 8 pm pacific time.
Come join us and ask us as many hard questions
in the Q&A as you'd like.
I only ask one thing, which is that if you
sing make it a little snappier than what we
just heard.
A cover of Journey, Fleetwood Mac or Frank
Sinatra would be preferable...